I just broke up with my boyfriend yikes
pull the ripcord it's time to get back
to work the show is whiskey Cavalier
Scott Foley plays an FBI agent lauren
cohan a CIA operative they're chasing
bad guys while trying to keep their
sexual attraction on the back burner I
will stay on my side do not worry couch
it is your on-screen chemistry is so
great how did you find that chemistry
off screen together we don't have it off
you don't it just happens on screen how
about a warning next time okay here you
might know him as one of Kerry
Washington's men on scandal while she's
familiar as a zombie chaser on The
Walking Dead you feel like your past
shows from Walking Dead in scandal
helped prepare you for this show
absolutely I can definitely speak for me
drink me to the show to get to do the
comedy and you know the storylines that
we have and then to do all these um all
these stunts in every episode kind of
betters the the previous we're getting
Bruce and Sybil moonlighting vibes from
this new action drama d and the European
locations just add to the glamour Oh
Special Agent will chase not telling you
anything
my turn
the title whiskey Cavalier comes from
Scots g-man code name and together these
two have a love-hate relationship that
looks pretty steamy my charm is like a
virus it is it's a charm virus and
before you know it boom you're infected
so you're gonna give me a virus
[Music]
[Applause]